in my mind the single greatest cover
and I think you agree based on what I
read in the book and you devote some
time to John Lennon who was the greatest
gift this planet has ever received in my
opinion but this cover that Annie
leiboviche with John and Yoko kind of
embracing one another on there he was
naked embracing Yoko who's in her
clothes they were lying on a bed the
Embrace was like the fetal position yeah
of him holding on to her like Mom or
mother something and it in the situation
in which it was published and the
picture was taken his assassination it
looked like uh almost as if it was a
death mask it looked it was something
called the pieda of our time and it was
so stunning and so strong about their
relationship about regressing to to the
womb you know of of going back to where
you came from a mother earth and just
all these kind of symbolic wonderful
themes that was powerful beyond belief
because of that moment did Annie
leibovich say to you here is the concept
or it was a John and yokos it was John
yoko's concept so I said fine you know
let's let's do that let's honor them
days later it you know became opposite
there was no other cover that you could
possibly have in this situation right it
was the first time we put an issue of
the magazine without any headlines on
our cover nothing needed to be said as
to what this was or what had happened
here and it was a beauty it's got such
power though it's hard to look at just
in a way sometimes it's hard for me to
listen to the Double Fantasy because it
recalls those days so well Yoko handed
you John's bloody glasses yeah
right after he was assassinated yeah
about a week later
in other words she had saved the glasses
that had yeah after his assassination
she was grieving I assume and then
handed them to you and you had them in
your hands yeah which wow it was spooky
spooky I mean what do you say what are
you doing what do you think
you get I think you get a real inward
moment
of the power of that object and what it
must mean and it kind of goes all
through you
of the consequence of the thing that
demands disappeared he's gone no more of
what this must mean to this woman
sitting next to me my his wife
the family the world the loss it's heavy
yeah
I mean you really had a real friendship
with him I mean he was obviously wasn't
that the first cover of Rolling Stone
the first like with the with John Lennon
from the movie how I won the war that
cover was just by accident we had no
money and so I was just looking through
the free movie Stills there was that one
and the fortuitous choice I mean John
himself in a movie and a political movie
it was kind of the three things we came
to specialize in a lot I have such
worship of John and the fact that I'll
never meet him so I can only imagine you
really had access to him as a person in
a personal way you played for John
Lennon let it be the movie he started to
cry right because he it meant to him
like oh my God I forgot how great The
Beatles were and we did break up it
broke his heart right from what I could
see there I mean he and Jane and me and
Yoko went to this empty theater and
washed altogether he had said he'd never
seen it before and we watched this film
and it's his story The Beatles breaking
up the version it has not been that came
out originally and I that's the way it
looked couldn't be more obvious than
fighting and all that stuff and we got
up here and he just we all threw our
arms around each other and cried because
it was the end of The Beatles and but
also he was at that time still in
therapy so he's he would cry in
everything you know but what made you
think to show him the movie I mean it
was his idea we were just hanging around
we had nothing to do particularly on a
Friday he said I haven't seen Let It Be
let's go see that
Wayne you must have been shocked too
like that hey you've never seen it oh my
God